You know, I told you over the last few months
that Dr. Anthony Foushee, who's the top infectious
disease doctor in the country, needs a security
detail because of threats against him.
And it's really a sort of glimpse, a peek
behind the curtain into the problems that
we have as a country here in the United States.
When the doctor trying to stop the pandemic
and save people has so many Americans wanting
to hurt him, furious with him, believing that
he is trying to hurt Americans, targeting
him as some kind of nefarious player in some
bizarre amalgam of conspiracy theories involving
Bill Gates and micro chipping in RFID and
all sorts of stuff, he needs security.
That's utterly unconscionable.
Think about how crazy it is that in most countries,
a pandemic comes.
Everybody defers to the public health officials
and to the doctors who specialize in infectious
disease, not in the U.S.
In the U.S., the pandemic comes and such a
large portion of the country is furious with
the doctors that the doctors end up needing
security to protect them from Americans.
Let that sink in.
Well, now it's even worse.
It's not just Dr. Foushee who is at risk.
Dr. Foushee admitted earlier this week that
now his daughters need security to protect
them because of the work that Dr. Foushee
is doing.
Dr. Foushee said he and his family have required
continued security in the face of harassment
and death threats because people are mad at
what he is doing in terms of the Corona virus
pandemic.
Trump said we have fifteen cases, which will
be zero soon in March.
People are mad at Dr. Foushee and threatening
his family.
A quote from a recent interview he did with
CNN commenting on this.
Dr. Foushee says, the unseemingly things that
crises bring out in the world.
I don't know if unseemingly.
I don't know if that makes sense.
But I'm quoting Dr. Foushee, the unseemingly
things that crises bring out in the world.
It brings out the best of people and the worst
of people and getting death threats to my
family and harassing my daughters to the point
where I have to get security.
It's amazing.
I wouldn't have imagined in my wildest dreams
that people who object to things that are
pure public health principles are so set against
it and don't like what you say and I say,
namely in the world of science, that they
actually threaten you.
I mean, that to me is just strange.
Now, what's really funny here is that Dr.
Foushee during this interview refers to there
being a degree of anti science sentiment in
the United States.
That is quite the understatement.
Half the country according to multiple.
Pulls doesn't even plan to get the coronavirus
vaccine.
If and when it is available to them.
But this is a this is a bigger issue.
This anti intellectual ism that underlies
all of this has been growing for a long time.
If you go back and read some of my favorite
authors, like the work of Carl Sagan from
decades ago, if you look at what Isaac Asimov
wrote decades ago, they saw it coming.
They've been sounding the alarm about not
sort of benign anti intellectual ism and anti
science and rejection of science in the United
States.
They have been sounding the alarm about the
real world impact that it was having and could
potentially have significantly more of.
They were completely correct.
And for all of these folks who talk about,
as I mentioned yesterday, Trump derangement
syndrome, which is just a term to stymie debate.
We, if anything, have been not alarmist enough
about this issue of rejection of science,
anti intellectual ism, and also pseudo intellectual
ism, which presents its own set of risks that
I've previously discussed.
Instead of revering our doctors and our scientists,
they've become enemies for I mean, would you
say it's for 20, 30, 40 percent of the country?
Imagine threatening someone for trying to
help the American people.
Imagine threatening the children of someone,
trying to help the American people.
And almost every day, Americans find new novel
ways to make the United States a laughing
stock and a global embarrassment.
And this is, in a sense, as I mentioned, you
know, when I mentioned Carl Sagan and Isaac
Asimov, this was predicted.
This is what happens after.
On the one hand, decades of underfunding schools
and not prioritizing, understanding science
and critical thinking and epistemology.
And you combine that with a political party,
the Republican Party that benefits from that
raises money on the basis of rejecting science
and also religiously based reactionary ideas,
although that's not at the core of what we're
seeing now with the virus necessarily.
There are more components.
I'm being overly simplistic, but those are
two big important pieces of the analysis.
Imagine what it's like for Dr. Foushee day
to day, going to work, trying to deal with
100 year pandemic, seeing other countries
successfully do it, and knowing that not only
are we failing because of the president, but
that the president is a huge part of why a
large portion of the country hates Dr. Foushee,
some to the point that they would like to
see him dead, redoubling my sentiments from
an earlier segment.
We owe the world an explanation and an apology.
And by the way, for if Trump wanted to stop
this.
If Donald Trump spent a week saying, leave
Dr. Foushee alone, I don't want to hear anything
about anybody going after Dr. Foushee or threatening
his family.
His interest is the health of the American
people.
If Trump did that, 95, 98, 99 percent of this
would stop.
But instead, Trump is actually part of the
problem rather than the solution.
Imagine being a health expert in the medical
field and having death threats hurled at you
and your family for trying to protect the
public and having the president of the United
States actually foment that treatment rather
than tell people to stop and to cut it out
for lack of a better term.
It's bad, really, really bad.